- Our kids are the same.
They're literally, constantly in costume.
- They're constantly dressing up.
And our kids are obsessed
with Wizard of Oz and Dorothy.
So, they've been Dorothy every year.
So we're like, well this year--
- That's financially awesome.
- Financially great.
But we're like let's you
know, maybe we could do
like a bloody Dorothy.
Like I can just put some
blood on you or something.
'Cause really, Dorothy again?
You wanna like, you know.
- But it's kind of awesome,
'cause what my daughter did was tell me
she wanted to be Princess in Black,
we're reading these books.
There is no costume for that.
I had to make it happen
and put it all together
with all of my free time, Eva.
(laughing)
And then, she was like
nevermind, I wanna be Anna.
And I'm like,
and then I get Anna and she's like
I don't know, Wonder Woman.
I'm like, you're gonna wear it.
I'm like my daughter changes
her mind all the time,
our five year old.
I would love it if she wanted
to be Dorothy every Halloween.
- Every Halloween.
- [Kelly] That's magical.
- So, what's she going with?
You don't know?
- I have no idea.
She can wear a sheet for all I care
and be a ghost at this point.
I am past it.
- Are you the kind of mom,
like do you make the thing.
You don't
- Hell no.
I get on Etsy with all those mamas
that have time to make stuff.
(laughing)
- I'm with you.